PayPal just came out of nowhere and made
a massive announcement they are
launching their own branded stablecoin
now why is this a huge deal well PayPal
has 426 million users around the world
and rather than go ahead and use an
existing stable coin or use Bitcoin they
are saying that they are going to have a
PayPal USD stable coin that'll be backed
one to one by US Dollars and you will be
able to send it to anyone that has
support for ethereum now why exactly is
this important well first let's look at
the PayPal announcement they dropped
this fire video to go ahead and tell the
world that PayPal is now moving into the
stablecoin game
[Music]
now in case you missed it there's four
things that they say that you're gonna
be able to do if you go ahead are one of
the eligible us users that use this
stable coin you'll be able to transfer
the stable coin between PayPal users and
compatible external wallets you'll also
be able to send people-to-people
payments using PayPal USD you'll be able
to fund purchases using this stablecoin
by selecting it at checkout with all of
the different retailers and you will be
able to convert any of PayPal supported
cryptocurrencies to and from PayPal USD
now when I went ahead and I looked
through the entire announcement there's
this one paragraph that was buried deep
down in the announcement and it told you
exactly why PayPal is doing this and
what they believe the benefit is going
to be for their users they said that
PayPal USD is designed to reduce
friction for inexperienced payments in
Virtual environments facilitate fast
transfers of value to support friends
and family send remittances or conduct
International payments enable direct
flows to developers and creators and
Foster the continued expansion into
digital assets by the law largest brands
in the world most of the current volume
of stable coins is used in web 3
specific environments and PayPal wants
to be compatible with those environments
starting on day one and soon you will be
able to use venmo as well now this makes
a ton of sense for PayPal to do they're
a payments company and users ultimately
they don't care what the interfaces that
they use they simply want to take
economic value that they have and send
it to an individual or to a business
whether they use PayPal or one of their
competitors doesn't really matter they
simply want it to be done cheap and
quickly and now PayPal has recognized
that there's a new technology on the
Block obviously Bitcoin was the first
cryptocurrency in the first blockchain
to reach any level of popularity but
PayPal has chosen to use ethereum and
the stable coin because if they don't go
ahead and embrace this technology
they're likely to be disrupted by it
that is the classic innovators dilemma
either you put yourself out of business
with new technology or someone else will
do it all you have to go back and look
at is Blockbuster and Netflix I think
Blockbuster would now wish that they had
listened a lot earlier so PayPal is
going to use this stable coin and as
they go ahead and try to disrupt
themselves there's a couple of other
things that we need to be aware of so
what exactly is going to be the benefit
for PayPal users well one of the most
important ideas in my mind is the fact
that you now will have PayPal become an
open network Jack maulers of strike is
the one who originally taught me this
the whole idea that open networks beat
closed networks a closed network is what
PayPal historically has been if you're a
PayPal user you could send value to
other PayPal users but you couldn't use
PayPal to send money to a cash app user
you had to use it within the closed
Network now that PayPal is going to use
a public blockchain and a stable coin
you would be able to send from your
PayPal account to anyone else that
supports that blockchain and so if cash
app was to integrate with ethereum or
erc20 standard you'd be able to send
that stablecoin from PayPal over to cash
app that is massive for these businesses
because it allows them to now
drastically increase their addressable
market and it gives new functionality
for their users but also PayPal is like
looking at the revenue opportunity that
is available to them as people come in
and adopt these stable coins they're
taking dollars and they're converting it
into a digital token those dollars go
sit in a bank account and then there's
interest that is derived from short-term
treasuries and other cash-like
instruments given that the interest rate
right now is so high PayPal could turn
this into a meaningful amount of revenue
for their business simply by driving
adoption of their PayPal stable coin now
these new technologies and these new
products they don't come without risk as
Jamal Sheikh pointed out on Twitter
there are some things that you need to
be very very careful of first if we look
at PayPal's code we can see that they
want to be able to freeze and unfreeze
accounts they also want to wipe Frozen
accounts and burn its tokens the supply
will be controlled by a central entity
aptly named the supply controller there
will also be assignment of asset
protection role two addresses tokens
will be able to be reclaimed back to the
owner and there will be older versions
of solidity that are used in the
compiler which is the same thing that
usdc moves now of course whenever you
hear the ability ability to freeze
accounts or wipe accounts of their
balances that scares the hell out of a
lot of people if we go back and we look
at all of the things that people did
using Financial tools As Weapons when
there was the Canadian truckers or even
during times of political protest it
should give you pause but the beauty
here is that you can go and look exactly
in the code base and see right where
PayPal is saying that they will have the
ability to freeze your account or to
wipe out that balance now many of these
concerns are the exact same thing
critics of Central Bank digital
currencies have been saying for years
now cbdc's have this great promise
they'd be the same exact native
currencies of these countries but it
would be in a new technology form factor
that would give central banks and
governments all kinds of new tools some
of the positives include the ability for
governments and central banks to be able
to get money in the hands of the people
as quickly as possible but also it comes
with the same downsides Not only would
they be able to freeze and unfreeze or
wipe balances but they also would be
able to see everything that you're doing
how much money is in your account who
are you spending it with at what time
what are you buying what are the amounts
all of that increase of surveillance
probably isn't worth the trade-off to be
able to send money a little bit cheaper
or a little bit faster using a stable
coin now we should go and look around
the world Central Bank digital
currencies are becoming more and more
popular as PayPal has now announced and
put into practice this stable coin they
beat the governments to the punch all of
these different countries have been
evaluating and researching what is going
to be the future of Central Bank digital
currencies but most of them are still
researching they haven't actually
created it and they definitely haven't
put it out in the market and so to see
PayPal having done this already is
pretty impressive but do not forget the
trade-off is not legacy currency versus
new stable coins there is Bitcoin
Bitcoin is the winner when it comes to
self-sovereignty and also it gives you
the ability to have a greater degree of
privacy while still having fast and
cheap payments now one last thing I want
to leave you with is that when PayPal
announced this the receptions seem to be
really positive people seem to be
excited and users were tweeting about it
all over the internet but if we go ahead
and we compare PayPal's reception to
Facebooks when they announce the Libra
digital currency it's very different
we go back in history and remember
Facebook wanted to create something
entirely new Libra and they were going
to back that digital currency with a
basket of nation-state currencies but of
course the day they announced it
politicians came out they wanted this
band they wanted Facebook to stop
development and there was Congressional
hearings that began to be organized
PayPal doesn't seem to be facing any of
that abrasive action instead they're
being received and people are saying
this sounds like a great idea my guess
is it's because PayPal specifically is
saying that this is a stable coin it's
backed one to one and you will be able
to redeem the stable coin for US dollars
at any time there's something to be said
about U.S politicians liking the idea of
a stablecoin being backed only by
dollars not by dollars and other
currencies and so PayPal seems to have
unlocked what the Playbook is going to
be Corporate America loves to be fast
followers it wouldn't surprise me if we
see a ton of other companies quickly
copy this Playbook as well could we see
Banks go ahead and launch their own
brand did stable coins well we saw JP
Morgan try to do JPM coin a couple years
ago and so we know that they're already
thinking about this they've already been
investigating it and they're trying to
figure it out if PayPal is successful in
driving adoption of the PayPal USD
stablecoin I expect every financial
institution to do something similar they
can make money they can drive more
functionality for their users and
ultimately allows them to eat more and
more of your wallet share we are
entering into a digital Financial system
where every single company is trying to
figure out how can they use these new
technologies to drive more of the money
that you have all throughout your
investment and banking accounts and
drive it onto their platforms we are
entering a world where the trade-off is
very clear you will have more
functionality you will have larger
market opportunity and you will be able
to send payments cheaper and faster but
you likely will have to give up all
sorts of privacy and other surveillance
concerns I personally am not excited
about that future sure I think it's one
that is very scary it's one that we
should be concerned with and it's one
that I would be very very hesitant to
walk into and so before you adopt these
Technologies please do your own research
please go look at what the
functionalities that are promised and
what the trade-offs are in terms of the
privacy and security that you'd be
giving up
at the end of the day each individual
person is a grown adult you can make
your own decisions but please be
educated before you do hopefully this
video was helpful for you to better
understand the PayPal stable coin once
you get done actually doing your own
research leave a comment and let me know
what you think of the PayPal stable coin
I hope this video was one data point
that'll help you but I highly suggest
you go read other resources once you let
me know I'd love to learn from each one
of you now this video is brought to you
by start engine the biggest fortunes
aren't made on Wall Street they used to
be made there but now they're being made
in private markets consider Mike Walsh
he put five thousand dollars into Uber
he's just a regular dude turned into
over 24 million dollars such
opportunities were once held behind
closed doors reserved for those with
connections or vast fortunes but not
anymore start engine is now going to
tear down that glass ceiling and make
startup Investments possible for you and
me the company is led by Howard marks
the co-founder of gaming giant
Activision and they got 1.7 million
users that have put in over 1.2 billion
dollars of transactions on the platform
but the best part is the platform's not
even backed by traditional Venture
capitalists it's backed basically by the
community they've raised over 75 million
dollars in crowdsource funding to date
go check them out at startengine.com you
can open up a start engine account today
and you can explore live investing
opportunities with starting investing
amounts as little as a hundred dollars
startengine.com go check them out today